نبدا من قطاع غزه حيث يجري تشيع جثامين 21
شخصا قضوا في حريق المبدا السكني بغزه وقد
عم القطاع اضراب عام واحداد على ارواح
الضحايا في وقت انت زادت فيها المطالبات
برفع الحصار عن غزه والسماح بادخال
مستلزمات الدفاع المدني
من مقبره بيت لاهيا شمال قطاع غزه مورس
الجزيره وائل الدحدوح في رسالتك السابقه
تابعنا نقل الجثامين سيرا على الاقدام الى
المقبره مقبره بيت لاهيا هل وصلت
هذا صحيح جلال ونحن فيه المقبره لكن هناك
حاله تداخل كبيره نظرا لاعداد الكبيره
حتى الان تتم عمليه مواراه الجسميه الثرى
الى مثواهم الاخير ابداعا واحدا الى الاخر
بحاله من حالات الصدمه
كبير جدا
وبالتالي لا يتناسب معه
حادثه حريق تحصل مرارا وتكرارا في كل
المجتمعات تقريبا لكن هذا ربما يصلي الضوء
على
الواقع الصعب
للاجهزه المختصه خصوصا فيما يتعلق به
الدفاع المدني الذي عاده ما ينبغي
للتعامل مع مثل هذه الحالات والحرائق
والكوارث وغيرها
وبالتالي يسلط الضوء على الواقع الذي تسبب
به الحصار المفروض على قطاع غزه من سته
عشر عاما وهو الامر الذي افضى به مجموعه
من المعدات والسيارات المتهلكه وحتى يعني
التدريب والكفاءه
اللازمه لمواجهه مثل هذه الاحداثيات ربما
تكون في حدودها الدنيا
وذلك نظر هي اجواء الحصان
بالتاكيد يعني
التساؤلات كثيره والتفاصيل كثيره
والروايات كثيره لكن السؤال الذي لا اجابه
له هو ما يتعلق بصمم الفعل اللجنه التي تم
تشكيلها من وزاره الداخليه والجهات
المعنيه هنا وذلك في محاوله للوقوف الى
السبب الرئيسي الذي احدث مثل هذا الحريق
الملعب بسرعه بشده قتل كل من كان في
المنزل لا احد تمكن من الخروج ليقدم شهاده
او روايه او معلومه يمكن ان تساهم في
رفض هذه اللجنه بالمعلومات اللازمه
وبالتالي التوصل الى تفاصيل دقيقه
بسبب الرئيسي رغم كل الحديث
في شقه
منزل مكون من اربع طبقات شكرا او دا بحياه
كل من كان في داخل هذا المنزل وهو ربما
موقف كل الفصائل والهيئات التي تطالب
بمعرفه السبب الرئيسي تفاديا تكرار مثل
هذا النوع من الحوادث شكرا لوائل دحدوح من
مقبره بيت لاهيا شمال قطاع غزه